hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the magnus carlson chess tour
it's magnus carlson vs hikaru nakamura
and it's game three of their yesterday's
match we said that we were gonna show it
even though we already know the result
of the match
uh but uh like i said uh hikaru started
with a win with the black pieces that
was in round one then game two ended in
a draw
uh the two draws we've shown in the
berlin defense where hikaru just uh
drew every game uh later i read that
hikaru was having some issues with the
camera and he was just
uh sort of uh well he
he wasn't very happy with uh with what
happened
i think he was fine like a thousand
dollars for
fixing the camera mid game or something
like that
i haven't really haven't really got to
the bottom of it but something was the
issue why hikaru accepted those early
draws with the white pieces
uh or so they say uh but this is game
three
uh the the one that i said i was going
to cover today because it's super super
complicated so
let's uh dive straight into it so magnus
with the white pieces opens with c4
he goes for the english opening with e5
and now
g3 uh we have knight to f6 and bishop to
g2 sophie and catering the the
uh lights for bishop we have d5 striking
in the center
and captures characters and here knight
to f3
so uh we have knight the c6 and castles
now by magnus and the knights the b6
uh this is the the very often played
line
we have b3 and bishop to e6 now and here
bishop to b2 is a known move however the
move magnus plays queen to c2 is a new
move in this setup of the english
and it is as of move 8 that we have a
completely new game so let's see how
hikaru deals with this he goes queen d7
he wants the castle queen side
so we're going to have a nice attacking
game with opposite side castles we have
rook to d1
preparing to strike in the center with
d4
and the castle's queen side by hikaru
knights to c3 and now
f6 strength strengthening that center
but of course magnus needs to
make a breakthrough somewhere so d4 uh
giving up upon for the moment it's
defended a lot of times but
this is what magnus is going for he
captures and not just bishop b2 captures
being impossible because the queen hangs
but he carol finds the very interesting
bishop to f5
with queen back to c1 and now d3
and now this is a problem uh as
well you kind of do have to capture the
pawn if you don't capture it
uh it's just going to stay there and if
you capture with the pawn then you no
longer have this
uh which is basically the reason why you
give up your pawn
so here and even d2 is the threat in
some lines so here we have e captures on
b3
and bishop to h3 by hikaru offering a
trait of light square bishops
magnus declines this and now bishop back
to g4 just spinning that knight
with d4 by magnus and now bishop to b4
not developing while attacking uh
although
you could have gone for let's say
captures captures and trying to win the
pawn but then you again
i don't know this is that doesn't seem
to be the the greatest way to
to go about it you you could have some
problems here and it is a rapid game you
don't want to
uh like uh be stranded like this for for
only one pawn
so after d4 we have bishop to be for by
hikaru and now
d5 by magnus now magnus even offers up a
pawn
for the exact same uh well pressure so
to say
we have bishop captures uh queen
captures and then now comes knight
captures on the e5 so the pawn is
captured
but queen to c4 and now you can see
there's a lot of pressure going on here
on this
d5 knight so hikaru needs to do
something about this he goes back
bishop to e6 and now he's up a pawn
and if he can defend properly then
that's perfectly fine
knight to d4 by magnus now challenging
the bishop here on e6 which would
remove one of the defenders of the
knight and here hikaru
just instinctively played bishop to f7
he doesn't want to give up the bishop
however the correct uh correct idea is
just captures here and after captures
you strengthen the knight with c6 adds
another defender
everything is everything is nice here uh
however hikaru just went bishop to f7
and this is a bit of a problem
so feel free to pause the video here and
figure out
why uh the line we've just shown is
better than this one well i'll give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
tactic involving queen g4 and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's
knight captures on c6 point being that
the queen now needs to
uh get away from the defense of the g4
square
because if you capture with the pawn
then it's just queen a6 check king here
and rocate the c1 putting pressure here
there's this there's this and it's just
going to be a very quick
game so here instead nakamura saw that
he needs to capture with the queen but
now queen to g for che
and here he was a very unhappy one he
saw this as he saw he's losing the g7
bomb
uh and here he cover played queen e6 but
there is the incredibly tricky however
in a rapid game not not likely to be
found a rook to d7
point is that after you capture your
bishop is already defended so you can go
this way
and now the the real idea is that if
queen captures an h7 and now black has
this beautiful queen sacrifice with
knight to f4
saying that i'm offering you a queen and
if you capture it
well if you don't capture it just knight
the knight to e2
check is coming and a lot of nasty ideas
will capture some d1 is an option
uh a lot of threats here so for example
if captures then just captures captures
and captures and this is checkmate as
the knight covers this square
so what you would have to do after
knight f4 is rook captures and b7
queen captures and now white would have
to go back black would still try to
sacrifice the queen with queen to
d1 check but now you have to block so
you can
you can capture with the rook and now
queen c2 we get this position where
uh where black black is definitely
better with all of this
pressure this is of course impossible
because of rook g8
and uh you know a lot of things uh would
happen here this is of course
all uh all uh with the idea that if
white captures the second point
as well if not then it's just a super
complicated game
uh but after queen g4 rook d7 definitely
the way to go however hikaru goes queen
to
e6 and now magnus grabs the g7 pawn
with rook h the g8 and now magnus is
offered the second pawn but he declines
this one he prefers to keep the queen
into the game
he grabs hold of the dark square
diagonal and
now queen to f5 by hikaru we have
bishop to g2 now with ideas of bishop to
h3 which would win the queen here
sohicar reacts to this king to b8 of
course
and now rook to d for magnus prepares to
double up
a double up rooks but not rook beat the
e uh
sorry rook beat the e8 preparing rook to
e2 to put pressure on the f2 pawn so
magnus needs to
needs to go back we have queen back to
d2 and now just
c6 strengthening that knight on d5
b4 is coming now a magnus will start
pushing on the queen side
to open up some files here and now queen
the h5 by hikaru
so now rook e2 is again is again the
idea so rook the e1 of course preventing
this
and now rook captures with queen
captures and rook to e8 again hoping to
get the rook to e2
so rook to e4 if you move the queen then
rookie 2 is coming so rookie 4
you offer a rook trade and hikaru
accepts rogue countries with
bishop captures and then now comes the
bishop of the g6
and magnus now the material on the board
is equal but magnus wants to keep his
bishop there so he moves the bishop back
and everything is nicely defended the
pawn is defended so there's uh there are
no problems here and magnus will just uh
well
enjoy this in the in the long run so
queen f5 by hikaru
and a3 now strengthening that pawn here
with queen to d3
getting the queen to square as active as
possible
and now h4 by magnus creating some
breathing room for the king
and also the pawns will be further
advanced if more pieces
are traded off so king c7 hikaru starts
bringing the king into the game
king h2 with queen to b1 sort of queen
to b1 now
offering a queen trade but also
attacking the bishop here
and magnus for the moment just keeps the
the tension going and here
uh hikaru uh could have continued in a
lot of ways could have played
queen queen c2 queen d3 continue
offering a queen trade and hope to
uh hope to you know survive the the end
game against the bishop fair however he
played bishop to e4 he wanted to trade
off the bishop
as soon as possible but now he gives
magnus a certain tactic so once again
feel free to pause the video and find
this tactic while i give you a couple of
seconds
and have a nice sip of my water
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
this is a free pawn and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
bishop captures on f6
point is that if the bishop is captured
queen f4 check picks up the knight king
d7 you can capture on f6 and now you
don't really care because if the bishops
traded
or traded off or not uh you just have a
three to one advantage on the king side
which is
more than enough to to win the game even
though you're up only one pawn
so here after bishop characters hikaru
tried bishop captures on g2 we have king
captures and now king the b6
uh getting the the king to a safer
square but now bishop c5
checked and again this situation is is
the same now magnus has a three to one
advantage on the king's side
so of course uh trading queens would be
very favorable so king b5 and now
bishop captures an a7 we have king the
a4 by hikaru and now
bishop back to c5 offering the a3 pawn
because if you capture this comes with
check you
trade down even further and then your
advantage on the king side becomes
even more impressive so bishop c5 we
have b5 by hikar
and now quinta e2 here magnus offers the
a3 pawn he's going after the base of the
pawn chain
so king captures and the queen the e6
with check we have queen to d3
and now uh magnus needs to check if
queen the e4 check will give hikaru some
ideas of a perpetual
uh but he decides nope and he captures
on c6
and now if you go for queen to e4 check
the king will simply move and you don't
have any good continuations
white will definitely get his move so
here
instead we have uh instead of this idea
idea with
not captures right away because then you
just uh put your knight into a pin so
first he carved one pins
but now magnus just goes queen to e6 now
pins the knight
this way queen to c4 now preparing to
pick up the b4 pawn and create a past b
pawn and now queen to f5 by magnus
with knight captures on b4 and here
magnus very gladly trades this captures
captures
and now queen captures an h7 uh it's
it's
it's too early to go queen to afford to
force a queen trade now but first you
eliminate the pawn
and now you would be more than happy
happy to uh to trade queens uh however
you want to get your pawns as far down
the board as
as possible or in this case up the board
so queen to d5
check we have king to h2 and now king
the a3 hikaru is now ready to push his
fast pawn
uh and queen to a7 check now king to b2
and we have queen the g7 check
king the a2 and now queen to g5 now
magnus offers a queen trade
but here it's different uh because here
if hikaru accepts and starts pushing his
pawn it seems that hikaru is faster
however magnus queens with check and
then of course it's completely winning
so after queen g5 we have queen to d3 by
hikaru
and now queen to c5 an excellent square
for carlson's queen
uh keeps an eye on the underpass pawn
keeps on the f2 pawn
supports uh the h5 push just a wonderful
square for the queen
so queen e2 by hikaru now h5 magnus
starts pushing his past pawn
queen b2 hikaru prepares to do the same
but carlson spawn is just now
much too fast so b4 we have h7 queen to
f6
even and now magnus doesn't want to
blunt blunder or anything so he just
gets the king to a safer square also now
the king guards this phone
b3 and but now comes queen to a7 check
and it was in this position on move 59
that hikaru nakamura resigned to the
game
as there is nothing more to be done here
and with this game magnus basically
equalized the match and forced uh
uh well he he got uh a draw in the
fourth game and then we went into the
blitz games which we saw yesterday
so here you resign because after you
move the king queen eight will be played
controlling the entire
light square diagonal so no checks will
be possible uh the white king is
perfectly safe and not only do you
control the light square diagonal which
it can be used to deliver checks you
also control the queening square so next
move
uh is h8 queen and that's it that's game
over
uh so yeah that's uh the game i do hope
you enjoyed it
and uh very happy that i was able to
show it as it's incredibly complicated
i would like to thank uh steven gebrart
uh mandy koshal brian paul cindy harris
and james morris for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the finals
check up on your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens
in the chess world so thank y'all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and here's another uh
photo of the sad hikaru there you have
it
see you soon